В ефірі актуальний випуск новин «heute 19 Uhr»
з Мітрієм Зіріним.
Добрий вечір всім!
А Крістін Отто згодом розповість
про жіночий теніс та футбол.
Цієї суботи поговоримо про такі теми:
Справи в раю -
підвищення рівня моря загрожує жителям Палау.
Міністерка закордонних справ ФРН закликає
до глобальної солідарності.
Газ і побоювання щодо зими -
міністр економіки Габек побоюється,
що можливе регулювання розподілу газу державою
випробує німців на міцність.
Тріумф на Вімблдонському турнірі
- представниця Казахстану Олена Рибакіна
перемогла Онс Жабер.
Для обох це був перший фінал турніру
«Великого шолому».
Дві мрії, дві кризи.
Під час зустрічі G20 на Балі міністерка
закордонних справ Анналена Бербок
гостро критикувала загарбницьку війну Росії.
В Палау,
острівній країні на південній частині Тихого океану,
Бербок привернула увагу до наслідків зміни клімату.
Минулої ночі міністерка закордонних справ прибула
з Балі до Палау.
Острівна держава розташована в Тихому океані
й складається з близько 500 островів.
Але через підвищення рівня моря
їм загрожує затоплення.
З огляду на серйозну загрозу Бербок
говорить про надзвичайну ситуацію
та закликає до активних дій.
Андреас Кинаст супроводжував
міністерку закордонних справ.
Більшість людей на Палау живуть на узбережжях,
які нині під загрозою.
На 3-й день подорожі Азійськими країнами
міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини
прибула до невеликої частини суші
серед вод Тихого океану.
Люди узбережжя Палау діляться своєю проблемою.
Нам не під силу контролювати
підвищення рівня води.
Тож залишається тільки запитувати партнерів,
як вони можуть нам допомогти.
Західні політики рідко навідуються до Палау.
Тому маленька республіка боїться
залишитися сам на сам з проблемою.
Бербок вдячна, що 19 000 жителів наполегливо
сигналізують про проблему.
Я маю зізнатися, що реакція міжнародної спільноти
була недостатньою, а підтримка - обмеженою.
На питання, чи зміна клімату є вагомою причиною,
щоб облетіти пів світу,
міністерка від партії Зелених Бербок
відповідає стверджувально - «Так».
Деякі речі настільки серйозні,
що їх треба побачити на власні очі.
Бербок використовує свої повноваження
та можливості, які відкриває посада у Федеральному
міністерстві закордонних справ,
щоб просувати свої пріоритети як на користь Німеччини,
яка нещодавно ступила на шлях нової кліматичної
політики, так і на свою користь.
Остання зупинка Бербок в її азійському відрядженні -
візит до Японії.
Увесь світ висловлює співчуття.
Вчора в Японії вбили експрем'єр-міністра Абе.
Папа Римський висловлює співчуття родині.
У Білому домі та в Індії на знак трауру за Абе
приспущено прапори.
Люди збиралися перед лікарнею,
де від вогнепальних поранень загинув
експрем'єр-міністр.
Попри напад Японія все ж не скасовує
завтрашні вибори до верхньої палати парламенту.
І хоча в країні діють
суворі закони щодо використання зброї,
наразі все ж обговорюються можливості для
посилення захисту політиків.
Ми вкрай рідко думаємо влітку про зиму,
але через загрозу з боку Москви
припинити постачання газу
занепокоєння щодо енергетичної кризи зростає.
Асоціація орендарів занепокоєна. Ситуація може стати
критичною для мільйонів орендарів.
Міністр економіки Габек попереджає
про випробування на міцність.
А канцлер стверджує, що тема енергетичної
безпеки Німеччини
буде актуальною ще протягом багатьох років.
Патриція Відемаєр знає більше.
Технічне обслуговування
«Північного потоку-1» ще не розпочато.
Ще не відомо, чи залишить Росія після цього
газовий кран перекритим.
Та кількість застережень та похмурих прогнозів
збільшується з кожним днем.
У відеозверненні з відомства канцлер говорить
про роки енергетичної незахищеності.
Нині наше завдання полягає
у забезпеченні країни енергією.
І цим питанням ми займатимемося ще тижнями,
місяцями, а то й роками.
Ми ухвалили багато рішень,
які допоможуть нам підготуватися
до нестачі газу,
будуємо трубопроводи та термінали зрідженого газу.
Ми працюємо над заповненням
газових сховищ.
Використовуємо вугільні електростанції,
щоб економити газ.
Міністр економіки Габек конкретизує.
В інтерв'ю на радіо він говорить про кризу, яка виникне,
якщо держава буде регулювати розподіл газу.
Цитата:
«Це буде справжнім політичним жахіттям.
Тож я не плекаю надій
ані щодо результатів можливих дебатів,
ані мого міністерства і навіть мене.
З таким випробовуванням на міцність Німеччина не стикалася
вже давно.»
Колишній і теперішній уряд робив і робить занадто мало
задля розбудови відновлюваних джерел енергії -
так звучить критика опозиції.
Нам потрібне встановлення граничної ціни та
заборона відключення електроенергії й газу.
Ніхто не має залишитися без газу через те,
що не може його оплатити
в умовах шаленого зростання цін.
Партія Лівих вимагає ввести податок на надприбуток.
Міністр економіки - збільшення допомоги населенню.
Канцлер запевняє, що Німеччина активно готується
до кризи енергопостачання.
Для багатьох з нас життя суттєво подорожчало.
За даними Федерального відомства статистики
станом на червень ціни зросли в середньому на 7,6%.
Натомість жителі Туреччини
можуть тільки мріяти про такий відсоток.
Там ціни зросли на 80%.
Репортаж зі Стамбула Штефана Шльоссера.
Своє життя вони можуть планувати тільки на завтра,
плану на післязавтра у них немає.
Зізнається Айтен Чорлу.
Вона працює кухарем в маленькому ресторанчику.
Раніше вони купували 5 кілограмів овочів,
сьогодні за таку ж ціну отримують лише 2.
Кожного ранку ми прокидаємося із думкою,
що ж сьогодні подорожчало,
і що ми зможемо запропонувати в меню.
Кожен похід до супермаркету
перетворюється на тортури.
Подорожчало все: енергія, оренда, продукти.
В порівнянні з попереднім роком
ціни зросли майже на 79%.
Влада ж робить акцент на зростанні та зайнятості.
Інфляція - другорядне питання.
На потреби народу президент заплющує очі.
Через високу інфляцію купівельна спроможність
наших громадян дещо знизилася.
Але ми нікого не залишили в біді
та без роботи.
Для більшості такі слова наче насмішка.
Понад 30% працівників у Туреччині отримують
мінімальну зарплату
та ледь зводять кінці з кінцями.
Нещодавно мінімальну зарплату підвищили
приблизно до 5500 лір, 310 євро.
Користі з цього ніякої,
адже згодом ціни на товари також зросли.
Куди не глянь - подорожчало все.
Грошей ніяк не вистачає.
Експерти припускають,
що ціни зростатимуть і надалі.
Невтішні прогнози. Зокрема для Айтен Чорлу.
Вона не знає, як довго ще протримається ресторан.
Про це говорили вже декілька днів,
а зараз цьому є офіційне підтвердження:
посла України в Німеччині, Андрія Мельника,
звільнено з посади.
Відповідний указ в другій половині дня
опублікував Офіс Президента в Києві.
Відкликано також кількох інших послів.
Нещодавно Мельника критикували
через його висловлювання
про українського націоналіста.
Він також неодноразово різко
критикував уряд Німеччини,
зокрема їхнє вагання щодо постачання зброї.
Перейдемо до актуальних подій війни в Україні.
Російська армія намагається
просуватися на території Донецької області.
Генеральний штаб ЗСУ повідомляє
про масовані обстріли
інших частин країни, як от Харкова.
Армія публікує відео,
де видно зруйновані російські танки.
Російські військові повідомляють
про обстріл складу з американськими гаубицями.
За їх словами було вбито десятки українських солдатів.
Від початку війни Білорусь на боці Росії.
Люди на Півночі України бояться,
що білоруські війська доєднаються до російської армії.
Тиждень тому президент Лукашенко повідомив,
що Україна нібито випустила ракети
по території Білорусі.
Дара Гасанзаде відвідав українське село Зірка,
що знаходиться неподалік від 1000-кілометрового
кордону з Білоруссю.
Ми прямуємо до білоруського кордону.
Туди, звідки розпочалося російське вторгнення,
і де й досі дислоковано
близько 30 тис. білоруських солдатів.
На перехресті Олена продає чорниці,
які вона зібрала в лісі.
Жінка також чула
про загострення небезпеки зі сторони Білорусі.
Чекаємо, що буде.
Наші підвали готові і ми теж.
З кожним кілометром трафік зменшується.
Мережа стільникового зв'язку вимкнена.
За селом починається закрита військова зона,
що неподалік від кордону з Білоруссю.
Зірка - це останнє село, до якого є вільний доступ.
Жителі спершу не могли повірити у те,
що розпочнеться війна.
Вони ж були «братніми» народами.
А тепер вважають вторгнення Білорусі цілком реальним.
Воно і віриться, і не віриться. Я думаю,
що вони знову прийдуть зі сторони Білорусі.
Минулого разу росіяни йшли саме цією вулицею,
тому ймовірно можуть пройти ще раз.
Валентина виховує двох дітей.
Як і односельці, вона чула,
що президент Зеленський спростовує
можливість вторгнення.
Вона також чула, що треба бути готовою.
Сьогодні дуже низько літав дрон.
Проте я не знаю чий він був.
Над селом Зірка нависає дамоклів меч,
який вже одного разу наніс удар.
На Шрі-Ланці прем'єр-міністр Вікремесінгхе
пішов у відставку унаслідок протестів.
Президент також склав повноваження.
Протестувальники увірвалися
до президентського палацу
та гнівно вимагали
відставки уряду та президента
через масштабну економічну кризу.
Поліція марно намагалась зупинити протести
за допомогою водометів, оточення та сльозогінного газу.
Острівна держава на південь від Індії втопає
у боргах та
ледве може імпортувати товари.
У Німеччині зростає кількість випадків
зараження коронавірусом.
Високі показники саме серед медпрацівників,
що перевантажує відділення інтенсивної терапії.
Це становить більш ніж половину від 700 відділень,
за словами президента інтенсивної
та швидкої медичної допомоги Маркса
в інтерв'ю для медіагрупи «Funke».
Наразі доступно на 2000 ліжок
менше, ніж минулого року.
Звісно пацієнтам вистачає невідкладної допомоги,
проте багато планових
операцій було відкладено - повідомив Маркс.
Всі цифри, дані та факти про коронавірус
та його варіанти
можна знайти онлайн на ZDFheute
та в нашому додатку.
У місті Байройт стався напад на місцевого політика.
За цим, ймовірно, стоять праві екстремісти.
Вірогідно, політика партії SPD
Халіла Тасделена спочатку образили
на расовому підґрунті, а потім вдарили по обличчю.
Поліція вже затримала
35-річного підозрюваного.
П'ятьом жінкам на літньому святі партії SPD
було підмішано «наркотик зґвалтування».
Берлінська поліція відкрила
справу за фактом важкого тілесного ушкодження.
Серед гостей був, зокрема, канцлер Шольц.
Соціальна мережа «Twitter» прагне у судовому порядку
змусити засновника компанії «Tesla» Ілона Маска
купити компанію
за 44 млрд доларів
відповідно до попередньої домовленості.
Нещодавно Маск відмовився від поглинання компанії.
Причиною називає велику
кількість фейкових профілів у Twitter,
яка була значно занижена.
Тепер сторонам загрожує судовий розгляд,
що може тягтися роками.
Між Twitter і Маском була укладена угода,
згідно з якою сторона, що порушить домовленості,
повинна сплатити мільярд доларів компенсації.
Для фанатів техно сьогодні чудовий день.
"Rave the Planet" повертається до своїх витоків
на берлінського параді «Love Parade».
На рубежі тисячоліть ця
Open-Air-вечірка була найбільшою на планеті
та збирала рейверів
всього світу в Берліні.
Пізніше її перемістили до Рурського регіону.
У 2010 році в місті Дуйсбург
під час тисняви загинула 21 людина.
Після чого вечірки не проводились.
Сьогодні була спроба згадати минуле у Берліні.
Репортаж Себастьяна Горскі:
Погода була проти рейверів сьогодні.
Проте майже 50 000 прихильникам техно,
які сьогодні в Берліні святкували відродження
«Love Parade», було байдуже.
Під новою назвою «Rave the Planet»
вони повернули 90-ті та пережили їх знову
під звучання 120 ударів на хвилину.
У такий складний час,
після двох років соціальної дистанції
та перебування вдома,
ми знову хочемо показати
наші уявлення про світ як про одну музичну родину.
«Знову разом» (англ. - «Together Again») -
техно-сім'я нарешті знову зібралась разом
під цим девізом, та
18 музичних машин з їхніми розкотистими техно-бітами
проїхали від проспекту Курфюрстендамм
до Колони перемоги.
Чимало ветеранів техно були там у 90-х,
а тепер відсвяткували зі своїми дітьми «сімейний рейв».
Дуже круто! Майже як тоді! Та й навіть краще!
Усі танцюють,
у чудовому гуморі та не штовхаються. Все класно!
Можна просто вимкнути голову
та насолоджуватись! Усім весело,
усі різного віку, трішки божевільні,
але весь світ зараз «crazy» (анл. «божевільний»)!
Зрештою сонце все ж вийшло до рейверів,
які між Колоною перемоги
та Бранденбурзькими воротами
святкували повернення техно-міфу Берліна.
Поговоримо про спорт, а саме про чемпіонат Європи
серед жінок, який почався неймовірно.
Чи не так?
Це точно! Далі буде ще краще.
Захоплення, пристрасть та радість від гри - те,
що можна сказати про чудову гру
німецької команди в Лондоні.
Після результату 4-0 проти Данії стартовий склад
дійсно заслужив на день без тренувань.
Сьогодні на тренуванні присутні не усі.
Вчора ввечері було жвавіше
на Брентфордському стадіоні.
Вся команда світилась від щастя,
адже своєю грою вони перевищили всі
очікування від початку турніру.
Я вважаю, що ми зіграли неймовірно
та показали чудову командну гру.
4:0 для початку - прекрасний результат.
Я пишаюся всією командою.
Ми згодні, адже після голу Ліни Магулль,
який вивів команду вперед, більше немає сумнівів.
Німецька команда дійсно розбила
Данію без шансу на виграш.
Наступні голи забили Леа Шуллер та
Лена Латтвайн, а також
капітанка Александра Попп,
яка лише видужала після коронавірусу.
Це був чудовий реванш після поразки у чвертьфіналі
проти скандинавської команди на останньому чемпіонаті.
Німецькі хокеїстки на траві також не відстають.
Вони зараз знаходяться у чвертьфіналі Чемпіонату світу.
Команда Валентина Альтенбурга відкрила першу гру
проти південно-африканок в Амстердамі
на першому турнірі з рахунком 1:0.
Гол належить Ніке Лоренц.
У вівторок відбудеться гра проти Нової Зеландії.
Представниця Казахстану Олена Рибакіна
стала чемпіонкою найважливішого тенісного
турніру світу - «Вімблдону».
Для неї та суперниці Онс Жабер, із Тунісу,
фінал турніру
«Великого шолому» був першим у карʼєрі.
Рибалкіна виграла у 3-х сетах.
Олена Рибакіна не може повірити у те, що відбувається,
після вирішальної подачі.
Вона не кричить, а скоріше полегшено видихає
після перемоги над Онс Жабер,
з Тунісу.
Після програшу в першому
сеті спортсменка зі зростом 1,84
ще мала змогу змінити хід гри на свою користь.
Онс Жабер доволі розчарована, що
не досягла мрії про отримання
першої нагороди турніру «Великого шолома»
спортсменкою африканського та арабського походження.
Герцогиня Кейт передала 23-річній переможниці
історичний трофей.
Казахстан, країна, що стала рідною для уродженки Росії
чотири роки тому, святкуватиме
зі всіма державними почестями
перемогу своєї нової суперзірки.
Тріумф Ваута ван Арта тривав два дні та
завершив восьмий етап «Тур де Франс».
Під час подолання траси Швейцарії
одягнутий у зелене бельгієць
після майже 190 кілометрів біля
Женевського озера в Лозанні
впорався з фінальним ривком.
Далі у жовтій майці словенець
Тадей Погачар, який фінішував третім.
Завтра турнір продовжиться в Альпах - чотири гори.
Це дійсно складно. Дякую, Крістін.
З погодою справа така:
на південному заході все ще багато сонця,
але й також будуть хмари та періодичні опади.
Детальніше від Оздена Терлі.
Однозначно рекомендую вам подивитись
о 22:45 "heute journal" з Марієттою Сломкою.
Ось і все від нас.
Насолоджуйтеся суботнім вечором і до зустрічі завтра.
Добрий вечір і ласкаво просимо до прогнозу погоди.
З північних напрямків до нас все ще
доходить прохолодне повітря,
зокрема також трохи опадів вночі та зранку.
Проте цей антициклон залишиться
з нами протягом тижня.
Гаряче повітря Іспанії
переміщатиметься через Францію
до Німеччини. Вночі буде дощ.
На півдні - більш хмарно.
На сході місцями дощі
у районі Балтійського та Північного морів
очікується сильний північно-східний вітер,
іноді зі штормовими поривами.
Тепер щодо мінімальних температур.
У Фогтланді - 9°,
8° у гірській частині землі Гессен,
в Ейфелі 9°.
Найвища температура
понад 10° зустрічатиметься північному заході.
Найтепліше буде
на південному заході - до 15°.
Завтра на півдні короткочасні дощі.
Сухо і багато сонця на південному заході.
Найвищі температури там становлять
25° та 16° у районі Фогтланда
Найближчими днями стане більш сухо.
У понеділок ще трохи дощу та 28° на сході.
Потім 30° у вівторок і 35° у середу.
Чудового вечора!